hello everyone and welcome to one of the
first games that finished from round 10
of this year's T still Masters it is Yan
pishi versus ding Len and if you guys
haven't been following what's been
happening in last year in in April they
played their world chair championship
match and it was a really thrilling
event trading blow for blow at the end
after 14 rounds of classical chess the
result was 7 to7 and then they went into
rapid tie breaks first three games ended
in a draw and then ding Len defeated
nepo in the fourth game becoming the
world classical Champion so uh no doubt
a heartbreaking event for nepo but what
are you going to do whenever there's a
one against one one has to be victorious
one has to be defeated but okay now you
you know a year after that you get a
chance U you you know you get another
crack at ding In classical here at Tata
steel so let's check it out it's a
really beautiful game neppo with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to E5 by ding Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5 going for
the Ru Lopez uh uh we have Pawn to A6
morphe's defense Bishop to A4 and now
Knight to F6 we have castles and now
Bishop D7 just a you know standard close
Dre Lopez D3 and now Pawn to B5 going
after the bishop Bishop to B3 and now
Pawn to D6 Pawn to C3 again nothing new
here we have castles and pawn to A4 now
going after that B5 Pawn uh Rook D1 is a
bit uh more common than A4 but A4 is
still very much played we have Bishop to
D7 and Bishop back to A2 and this
unprovoked bishop to A2 is fairly rare
H6 and now Pawn to H3 and here just Rook
to E8 and there is a game was played in
2011 between Peter Sidler and Michael
Adams uh in that game Rook to E1 was
played but here we have Bishop to E3 by
nippo and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so okay d
goes Rook to B8 again another standard
move uh Knight B to D2 and now B Bishop
to f8 now you could also consider
capturing on A4 and then capturing on B2
it's not that it's bad it's even the top
move recommended by the engine but it
just looks weird you know you're trading
down uh without achieving all that much
you do have an active Rook but uh I mean
it's nothing spectacular uh so instead
we have Bishop to f8 ding just keeps the
tension and now Pawn to G4 nippo goes
for the attack G4 G5 is coming so okay
ding goes Bishop to E6 he wants to
counter nippo strong Bishop on A2 uh
Bishop captures on E6 we have Rook
captures and now a captures on B5 we
have a captures uh and now Pawn to G5
going after the Knight on F6 H captures
on G5 and now Knight captures on G5 you
could go for Bishop captures H but
Bishop the E7 and you don't really
you're not really pinning anything so
here Knight captures on G5 uh Rook back
to E8 and now King to H2 now nippo
hoping to get his Rook into the game uh
via the G file uh but ding strikes in
the center with Pawn to D5 as nepo king
is wide open here it's of course Very
principled to open up the center as well
uh Rook to G1 Now Pawn to D4 we have
captures captures Bishop to F4 and now
Bishop to D6 trying to trade off the
dark Square Bishops uh Bishop to G3 and
ding just trades Bishop captures on G3
where nepo could capture with the Pawn
With The Rook or with the King and
capturing with the pawn would be a
little bit weird and uh also maybe with
a king but it's actually perfectly fine
uh he captures with the Rook ding
immediately pins it Queen to D6 and now
King back to G1 the reason why you don't
play something like Queen F3 and then
try to double up is that it doesn't
achieve all that much for example G6
you're going to play Rook to G1 uh
Knight E5 attacks the queen forces the
queen back and after Queen E2 or queen
to D1 Knight to H5 and um you know black
is much much better you don't have Queen
captures on H5 G captures because
there's no good um uh jump with the
Knight if you could somehow pick up the
the black queen while you ratted maybe
it's possible but you don't so after
Queen to D6 just King to G1 nicely
unpinning and now Rook to A8 offering a
rook trade uh nippo goes for a rook
trade captures captures and now Queen to
B3 putting pressure on the F7 Pawn so
Queen to D7 ding just defends it and now
Knight D to F3 uh capturing the B Pawn
while it is possible it's um really an
invitation to an early draw you you have
to see that the Knight covers the A5
Square Rook to A5 is possible the Knight
here can get attacked and if you capture
on B5 then just Knight to H5 will attack
the rook and now you don't have a better
option than to repeat Rook to G4 Knight
F6 Rook back to G3 Knight back to H5
because if the Rook moves just Rook A5
wins the Knight on G5 so capturing the B
Pawn that doesn't really do anything so
Knight D2 F3 by nepo uh Rook to B8 and
now Queen back to C2 putting pressure on
the Knight so the queen has to be
careful Rook to B6 adding another
Defender to the Knight and now Pawn to
E5 and this Pawn to E5 is uh now very
useful you will not have to worry about
any Knight H5 Knight to F6 action so
Knight H5 does attack The Rook but Rook
G4 and now there is no Knight to F6 and
here H it's very hard to find the move
for Ding and ding was already down to I
believe 20 minutes on the clock so it's
not anything serious uh 20 minutes is
you know enough for ding to make n nine
moves in any position but here he just
doesn't find it here you have to play
the centralizing Queen D5 and it looks
like a great move to play even if you
don't know what uh it does it just I
mean look at this position with the
queen on D7 and now look at the position
with the queen on D5 it's a much better
position and uh if you if you try to
throw in some moves let's say queen to
C1 for the queen to enter the king side
uh Pawn to F6 already you get a trade
here with an attack on the rook and if
Rook H4 four yes looks very nice you'll
just bring the Rook back Rook B8 and
it's a game nothing spectacular
Happening Here If Queen to F4 uh yeah
it's a fine move but nothing really uh
you can easily defend the pawn and you
know the game continues but in the game
ding played Rook to B8 and here he just
started loitering with the Rook uh uh
without um you know giving giving it any
purpose and nepo played Queen to C5 it's
a very very strong um idea but I'm going
to show you one that wins uh just you
know straight up but it's very hard to
see and that is Knight to
E4 uh really uh a beautiful move and now
it's uh very very hard to play but uh
the the problem is uh it's also very
hard to see why it's winning for example
Knight to d8 all of a sudden Queen to D2
is coming and now how do you how do you
respond to this with black the queen is
coming to G5 there's just no good option
here The Rook is stuck here uh otherwise
Queen G B5 will also come with an attack
on this Knight and on this knight uh if
you play Queen to F5 to stop that then
Knight to H4 just gets rid of the queen
and if Queen captures on E5 now Rook G5
will win material here so it's a uh
something an engine would play uh but
you know just wanted to share it with
you uh but in the game Queen to C5 was
played also very hard for dink to find
the move here and the only move that the
dink should play is Knight back to B6
this Rook to B8 move was just a bad idea
but still even if even after this Rook
to B6 move E6 is coming E6 is coming in
all the lines and there's just no good
way to stop it due to the Knight hanging
here on H5 and after captures captures
is just a much better position for nepo
although okay maybe if he doesn't play
it perfectly maybe there's still a way
for ding to defend however ding played
Rook to e sorry not Rook to E8 ding
played Rook to d8 Rook to d8 would would
have been better than Rook to d8 uh and
now it's uh completely winning for nepo
but uh again you can play a lot of
things here in the game Knight to E4 was
played but I'm just going to show you
what E6 does as I know you guys are
looking at it if F captures then Knight
to E4 and now look at this the Knight
here is hanging how do you defend it
only way to do it is uh Queen to D5 the
Knight has no squares uh if you move it
to to F4 to sort of give up the Knight
then Knight F6 check picks up the queen
as the G Pawn is pinned and if you play
Queen to D5 looks great you you know get
rid of everything but there's Rook G5
attacking the queen and now if you trade
Queens you don't capture with the Knight
you capture with the rook and both of
the knights are hanging and that's it
black resigns so that's uh one way to do
it with Pawn to E6 but nepo went for
Knight to E4 first and now look at this
queen to E6 ding blocks the pawn so he
doesn't allow Pawn to E6 but now the
position is completely winning so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for nepo while I give
you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on helping nepo exact
his revenge uh for losing the world CH
championship match and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook to H4 that is the way to do it as
we know the Knight has no squares and um
yeah it's a very sad position for ding
G6 well it can be played Rook captures
on H five just um completely El
eliminates all all defensive ideas that
Ding might have but similar thing um
sort of was in the game so we're going
to we're going to skip that line in the
game Rook to D5 was played attacking the
queen here but now nipo just played
Queen to A3 and with the possibility of
this queen to A8 check and the king not
having access to the H file if the
Knight moves uh there's just no good
move here for example if you play Queen
to F5 uh all of a sudden Queen to A8
with check and now you cannot block with
the Rook because the Knight hangs and
you cannot block with the Knight because
the Rook hangs very very tricky stuff
here so instead after Queen to A3 G6 was
played now but here ding sorry nepo just
played Knight G Knight F to G5 and he
was in this position on moveed 36 that
Ding L world champion ding Len resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here so uh both of them having a
tough event both of them with two losses
so far and this is now ding's third loss
in classical chess in one event um very
very very hard you know for for him
after uh being away from classical chess
for so long and um you know especially
taking a beating on his rating uh but
what are you going to do but what's fun
here is why it
um uh why this move is so strong uh well
uh there are other ways to do it I'm
just going to show you a few of them
because the the game is now over you
could capture on H5 right away like
we've discussed it in the previous line
and if G captures now Knight the F6 with
a nice Fork here and after King G7 you
play Knight cap captures on H5 and look
at this now the king cannot go to f8 The
Queen Is Stopping that so the king comes
to H6 but now you play Knight to F4
again with the fork the queen and Rook
are attacked and now you either uh stop
check and uh lose the Rook on D5 or you
somehow try to defend the rook and then
you just get checkmated Queen f8 check
King H7 and now Knight to G5 Checkmate
beautiful stuff here uh that's one way
to do it nepo decided to go Knight F to
G5 but it was also enough uh because you
have two ways to maybe defend this one
is to go back with Queen to C8 to stop
Queen to A8 with check but then again
Rook captures on H5 and after G captures
Knight to F6 comes with check and after
King G7 you just pick up the Rook so if
the queen moves from the defense of the
Rook this is how it ends and there's
even a more beautiful way to do things
after this Knight um after to G5 if you
try Queen captures an E5 so you don't
stop the check on the back rank then is
Queen to A8 with check Knight to d8
blocking now it's possible because the
queen defends The Rook H but that's the
question is the queen really defending
that Rook look at it look at it real
closely no it's not uh because Rook
captures on H5 G captures and now Queen
captures on D5 that's the good stuff
Queen captures Knight to F6 with check
uh and uh the the line ends with um nepo
being up a full piece for example King
to G7 Knight captures on D5 and nepo is
just up a full Knight so ding is of
course very strong he saw all of this
and he said all right I don't want I
don't want any of this uh you know I'm
disgusted by this game uh so it was
unmoved 36 that Ding resigned the game
beautiful stuff by nepo and uh for those
of you I don't know I think a lot of the
other games are still being played but
just in case they're not let me just
quickly
check uh I'm sure some of you maybe even
don't want to know the results of other
games but yeah all of the games are
still being played some of them seem to
you know uh be going into decisive way
uh but we'll see you know still uh
probably probably will be played a long
time uh but yeah use that hashtag
suggestion if you have any of your own
favorites and I will be glad to go over
them so very nicely done by nepo I would
like to thank Len Herbert Y young
Anonymous
person and Christopher and rud brette
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day